dann erzähl meister bordeaux dieser
flüssigkeit
es ist ein film über den ich eigentlich
gar nicht viel sagen möchte
du denkst man deine krankheiten du hast
so viel zeit
[Musik]
mal ehrlich die x ich habe mehrfach
gesehen und jedesmal derartig beglückt
hat dass sich das einzige was ich sagen
möchte wirklich erst gehen sie hingucken
mehrfach gleich am besten
und vielleicht können sie genauso
glücklich aus angeblich gut für mein
herz sein sollen trinkst du wenigstens
die milch werde ich doch nicht gegen
alles und ich nur sagen als ich gehört
habe ein motorrad ein film über einen
kranken altern im film regisseur gedreht
der keine filme mehr drehen kann weil
ihm alles wieder durchgegangen dass will
ich auf keinen fall sehen aber dann
stellt es sich eben heraus dieses ist
ein typischer almodóvar film das heißt
embedded über von v+ ermordet über von
dem gefühl dass eine welt wirklich nur
aus kunst gratis 32 es ist schön dass
wir bäume da standen vielleicht pinien
und jetzt erkläre mir verdammt noch mal
warum du nach 32 jahren hier auftaucht
und dass die hauptfigur dieser alternde
regisseur wird man auch gespielt von
angela müth junior an der das denkmal
auf jedem also ich jedenfalls coupé dem
waren sie nicht gerne zu und er ist hier
in absoluter höchstform
weil er uns etwas eine eine figur zeigt
die gleichzeitig eine projektion ist die
gleichzeitig eine fantasie ist die
gleichzeitig eine halluzination ist und
so ist dieser ganze 5
ich wär so gern ein mann dann könnte ich
jetzt nackt im fußball
die mutig für den hass rosita anklage
ich euch mal wieder da und hat das
gefühl man taucht ein in ein leben aber
auch in einen raum und in eine drogen
halluzination drucken spielen auf eine
rolle und alles was ein motor wichtig
ist und das ist natürlich vor allen
dingen das begehren und die liebe und
seine mutter hat alles einen großen
platz in diesem film und seine eigenen
alten filme seiner anderen filme kommen
auch vor allerdings werden sie nicht
zitiert dass wir noch sonst keine großen
hinweise mehr zum fällen gegeben sondern
man hat den eindruck dass die atmosphäre
von vol wer zum beispiel ist in seinen
kindheitserinnerungen in diesem film
jetzt in dem neuen light und
herrlichkeiten rolle spielen aufgehoben
das gesetz der begierde kommt vor in
einem filmprojekt in einem monolog wenn
ich das erste mal dass ich in so aber in
dieser nacht man hat das gefühl es ist
ein film der wie die haut das gewebe
eines körpers diesem werk körper
eigentlich und fasst das heißt ein traum
auch visuell erreichte eine ungeheure
gefühls reichtum in diesem film
ich glaube das ist das was so beglückend
als dass man es wirklich über mit nichts
kurz gehalten wird so eine demütigung
lasse ich bin ich noch mal
nicht klar ist ist einer wenn ich der
beste almodóvar obwohl er in seinem
frühwerk ganz viele filme die ich
wirklich liebe ist eine historische
porträts ein künstlerisches porträt es
ist und trotzdem hat es überhaupt nichts
enthüllen dass es enthüllt gar nichts
über almodóvar des wenig wissen wollen
oder sollten sondern es ist einfach ein
hochkomplexes konzert
[Musik]